BLUES LOOKING GOOD RIGHT NOW.
>> SCHENN. PASS FOR BUCNHEVICH G
THEIR D ON ALMOST EVERY RUSH.
THEY'RE NOT AFRAID TO
WE TALK ABOUT ALSO BARKOV BACK
IN THE LINEUP FOR BARKOV IN FOR
BENNETT.
HE LEAVES THE CLUB WITH THREE H.
WIRED BACK IN BY BORTUZZO.N THE.
>> Jamie: LOOKING FOR IT.
HE ISR.
THAT IS KNOCKED OUT OF MIDAIR,
NOW BACK TO HUSSO IS EQUAL TO TE
TASKHOT. SHOT WIDE TO KRUG.
THAT SHOT ON GOAL.
THE BLUES
SPOT, AS WE WATCH HERE IVAN
BARBASHEV WITH A COUPLE OF GOOD
CHANCES.
THE
4:20.
THE BLUES LINE ACROSS NOW.
SHOT ON GOAL.
SAVE BY HUSSO.
FUNNELED AROUN
BLUE LINE.
THESE>> Andy: CONGRATS TO YOU AD
THE FAMILY.
>>CE-OFF.
TARASENKO.
HE DUSTED OFF.
HE SCORED THE HERE.
PLAY, GET SOME HELP THERE TO
O'REILLY
SABRE,
WIDE OPEN OFF THE CROSSBAR!
BARBASHEVOAL FOR THE BLUES.
THAT PUCK LUCE, SHOT ON GOAL.
A VERHAEGE IS IN THE NET.
SHOT AND THEY SCORE!
BACKDOOR
GREAT PASS BY RADKO GUDAS, VILLE
HUSSO, N, AND
WEWEE ANOTHER ONE.